ça va oui j'ai un petit peu envie d'en
savoir un peu plus sur valérie lemercier
j'ai vu votre spectacle
on peut commencer pas de problème non
plus j'ai tout mon temps
j'aime bien votre émission alors d'où
venez vous d'abord c'est quoi la famille
l'entourage la renardière tiens c'est
quoi
quand tu connais pas la renardière c'est
génial ça fait les centaines d'années
connaît là-bas on est ravi l'été on fait
des grandes tablées on aime en der en
plus on retrouve tout le temps l'état de
coûts dans les collèges maman comme a
pas vus depuis des années comme débité
normes
je voulais savoir avec ce spectacle va
être difficile d'avoir un moment pour
soi pour s'occuper de sa maison
non robin je commence mon linge le
dimanche matin comme ça c'est bien
j'ai ma journée oui je fais mais les
nerfs jane harman matin mais après
manger je fais mes machines
en général je fais une à 48 des 81
disent oui oh oui oh oui moi tout ce qui
est une honte je fais bouillir
vous vous intéressez je pense à ce qui
se passe un petit peu autour de vous non
est ce que vous seriez prête à vous
engager personnellement service d'une
cause humanitaire les enfants dans le
monde etc
bah oui parce que tu sais quand je serai
grande est ma je m'occuperai de tous ses
enfants parce que tu sais des petits
noirs on croit qu'ils sont gros accident
avant vente mais c'est parce que je
kiffe tellement ils sont maigres
bah oui parce que comme ils ont très
faim et baïse à val de l'eyre alors ils
font comme ça fait mal très mignonne
avez vous envie parfois de crier de
mettre les poings sur la table de faire
valser ce qui vous entoure les gens les
choses
attendez là non mais vous pouvez
continuer à poser des questions mais
c'est possible de parler un peu moins
fort je suis vraiment crevé en plus je
viens de passer impartiale d'urbanisme
pas de problème je peux mais je m'en
fous complètement
et alors là valérie qui sommeille en
vous l'autre scène qu'on ne voit pas
comment est-elle en ligne messieurs le
royal et pendrel lycéens pouvaient se
calmer un appel parce que 20 heures
j'ai un petit peu envie de vous poser la
question finalement est ce que est ce
que vous êtes angoissé
parce que c'est vrai on dit parfois que
les comiques dans la vie ne sont pas
toujours très gai très drôle c'est vrai
ça c'est pau pour bien fossiles non pour
les comme c'est indirect de télévision
avant je t'ai peau bien je vieillis sur
l'eau se vaut mieux je dis pas que je
suis rendu mais j'ai comme l'impression
d'être au bout du tunnel
volot oui je comprends bien et qu'est ce
qui vous fait le plus rire chez les gens
leur humour et quels sont vos rapports
avec les autres comiques les femmes
comique mieux eux mais elles ont un
grand qui les prennent toute la place de
seconde 1,3615 y existe et voreppe avec
le théâtre en général d'un violent
raiponce chien est normal on 10 10 10 10
on n'est pas chez les grecs
niort vient et puis je vais terminer en
vous demandant tout simplement votre mot
préféré sarabande et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater
devine alors dit tu es abonné vous
mettez un pouce bleus